hi I'm Alan Joyce director of content
development for Wolfram Alpha and I am
here to give an overview of new
functionality and version 11 related to
the Wolfram languages entity framework
and other built-in data from the Wolfram
knowledge base there are several major
categories of improvement since version
10 first the introduction of implicit
entities and entity classes allowing
users to select entities by different
criteria including ranked property
values such as largest and smallest
second the ability to instantiate
certain kinds of entities by specifying
quantities dates or other
characteristics and the ability to
create groups of entities that can be
operated on as a single unit third the
ability to create custom user defined
entity types and entity collections and
interact with them using standard
Wolfram language entity framework syntax
and finally a number of new data related
functions as well as new built-in entity
types and other improvements in
expansion of Wolfram knowledge based
content so first implicit entities and
entity classes this frequently requested
functionality allows you to select
entities from many built-in types using
a simple but powerful syntax for
filtering and ordering by combinations
of properties so here we have the
semantic interpretation of mountains
higher than 6,800 meters and it's in
port form apply entity lists to this
implicit entity class and you get the
list of entities that meet that
selection criteria and then that list
can be operated on in customary ways
retrieve and convert property values
plot entities using built-in Geographics
functionality and so on implicit entity
class definitions can be quite complex
as seen here where we're selecting
metallic elements within a certain
density range and with a certain minimum
melting point and we can also make use
of other recent additions such as
contains any between greater than take
largest and so on anthony instance is
another powerful new symbol which allows
you to specify absolute quantities of
certain kinds of entities so here we see
that you can compute properties of a
specific mass of acetone you can also
instantiate a country or historical
country entity using a date
specification
and retrieve properties including
polygons that apply to that specific
year or you can specify parameters for a
particular physical system here we have
the default values for magnetic vector
potential in a circular current loop and
here we have that entity instantiated
with particular parameters entity groups
are another new construct by default
entity value retrieves values for each
entity in a list but by using entity
group you can retrieve one value for the
extensive properties of a set of
entities also new in version 11 we have
custom entities in the form of a new
entity store object this has been
another frequently requested feature
since the release of version 10 for
those who are interested there's code
here to construct the data set of UFO
sightings in the United States but the
main point is that using entity store
you can take that data set and instantly
turn it into a new entity type that
works with the standard functions in the
entity framework just like they do for
built-in entities you can retrieve lists
of properties select random entities and
so on here we even use an implicit
entity class to select sightings by a
visual type property and plot the
results on a map here's one other
example making use of a Wolfram curated
entity store that lives in the new
Wolfram data repository this entity
store actually contains three different
entity types related to NSF grants are
awarded in 2015 one type for grants one
for investigators and one for
institutions these can all be retrieved
and registered in your local session and
immediately used in all kinds of
analysis and visualization for example
here visualizing the distribution of
grant sizes on a logarithmic scale these
are some of the most exciting pieces of
brand new functionality in the entity
framework but of course we've also
continued to expand the number of data
specific functions built into the
language here's a view of some notable
data functions that have been added
since version 10 and here are some
specific examples for one using
mathematical function data to retrieve
properties of a given function or 4g 0
gravity model data and geomagnetic model
data here retrieving gravitational
components at Big Ben and here
visualizing the magnetic field over
Canada there are also a number of brand
new built-in entity domains notably food
which currently includes nutritional and
other data about more than 37,000 foods
here for example we have the semantic
representation of a Red Delicious apple
and here we have the more than 500 data
points that can be available for a given
food and of course this domain works
with natural language input as well as
new symbols like entity group here we
can find the Wolfram language
representation of and the caloric
content of a typical healthy breakfast
another very exciting addition is human
anatomy with data on tens of thousands
of anatomical structures including 3d
geometry for many structures here we use
the new anatomy plot 3d function to show
a cutaway view of a human hand
highlighting four different bones or if
human anatomy isn't fun enough for you
you can of course programmatically
transform human and anatomical
structures into a nice alien head we've
also added a great deal of data related
to languages with new entity types for
writing scripts and alphabets and
alignment across entity types to enable
some interesting cross domain lookups
and we've continued to add and expand
our collection in many other directions
with data on everything from Pokemon
here we have everything you might want
to know about Pikachu to yoga poses and
we're constantly adding new domains and
expanding and improving connections
between existing entity types with new
improvements rolling out regularly thank
you